how's it going i'm gabe hill writer this
is hashtag news and you guys are Newsies
I've just W that you can't change it
you're Newsies we're talking about Game
of Thrones season 6 and as the season
approaches closer more and more details
are starting to spill out some of the
most exciting stuff has been about
badass characters that are making their
long-awaited return to Thrones these are
people who made huge impressions and
then just kind of disappeared off the
show but now it sounds like they're back
also though there's a rumor we might be
getting a super badass character from
the books that's never been introduced
on the show at all these might be major
spoilers if these rumors come to pass so
you've been warned
ok right up top let's address the dead
elephant in the room and yes I am
calling Jon Snow fat seems like he's
coming back if you're watching this
video you probably knew that already we
don't know the exact details of his
return if it happens though we figured
it's definitely worth a mention
but another stark boy is returning this
season for sure and that's bran Stark
except now he's probably got magical
freaking powers thanks to that creepy
old man who lives in a tree I love that
lullaby another not yet confirmed but
could also still return little boy is
Rickon Stark him and OSHA is caretaker
or am ia but I wouldn't be surprised if
we see them back in season 6
especially you can't wait to see what
puberty has done to the actor playing
reckon but that's just me it's always
fun to see what middle school and life
has done to these poor bastards ok
another character definitely returning
is head of the Tully clan Catelyn
Stark's uncle Brendan the blackfish
Thole he'll also be joined by ed Myrtle
II who is Caitlin and Liza's little
brother a lot of people forget the red
wedding was Ed Murs wedding but he
didn't die Walder Frey that old mean
jerk married off his daughter Roslyn to
Ed myrrh then he says he was just kept
in a dungeon on his wedding night uncle
Brendan got away from the red wedding
because he was luckily out peeing at
that moment can't tell you how many
times being has saved me from a Jan huge
book spoiler here ready are you Rick are
you guys ready I'm not gonna say if
we're not ready Lady Stoneheart
those of you don't know that's the name
of the resurrected zombie version of
Catelyn Stark she comes back as a
freaking murdery executioner in the
books and her killing rampage could make
its way onto the show yes
zombie murder crunch oh this rumors
definitely not confirmed though so don't
go saying I'm saying things I didn't say
okay even though I'm technically a man
right now
and now for my burning questions burning
questions usually weren't burning
responses that means you guys right now
with the comments clickety-click
ticktick oh yeah what do you say oh yeah
yeah one bran is back but what powers
really have it's got to be more than
just the wording he could already do
before he's got a bigger or better right
I know a lot of people are thinking
flight which would be freakin crazy but
his legs still don't work so that just
kind of look like a well you can picture
that too what are the chances Lady
Stoneheart is really gonna show up
that's a pretty insane thing for them to
do on the show and if she's coming which
characters in the show will be on her
murder list here's hoping fimo three who
else do you think is coming back we've
been over some major people that we
think but have you heard about any other
characters returning maybe from the
long-lost days of season three I think I
heard something about more people who
have been loyal to the Starks which gets
me excited about a certain epic battle
that I made another video about you can
check that out here and the rest of our
Game of Thrones coverage now is our
favorite part of the video where you
guys get to subscribe good that good
perfect
I'm Gabe Hill writer and I personally am
excited that I finally get to do my Lady
Stoneheart cosplay and people will
recognize it I mean I wear to Starbucks
whenever I get in like it's weird
I get looks weird looks
you